en los últimos vídeos hemos hablado
acerca de la idea de una matriz que en
realidad solamente es un arreglo de
números que usualmente se hace de dos
por dos un arreglo bidimensional de
hecho casi siempre utilizamos un arreglo
bidimensional sin embargo visto de una
forma general si tengo una matriz de m
por n m es solamente el número de filas
y n es el número de columnas filas por
columnas entonces dejen de escribir una
matriz de m por n por aquí de una manera
general voy a llamar a esta matriz a y
bueno recuerda que las matrices se
denotan con mayúscula y con negritas y
esta matriz a es igual aquí en la
primera entrada es esta la llamaré a
minúscula y está en la fila 1 columna 1
la siguiente entrada está en la fila 1
columna 2 y así nos seguimos que las n
columnas que tiene esta matriz hasta
llegar a la componente que está en la
fila 1 columna en él y ahora vamos a
fijarnos en las filas aquí abajo
tendremos la componente a minúscula fila
2 columna
y así hasta pasar por las filas hasta
llegar a la componente que tiene la fila
m columna 1 y bueno vamos a rellenar un
poco más esta matriz aquí tendríamos la
componente 2 2 ya está acá tendríamos la
componente a minúscula que está en la
fila m columna n y aquí ya tenemos
nuestra matriz a y bueno seguramente tú
ya has escuchado un poco de matrices
porque esto es lo que has visto en sus
cursos por ejemplo de álgebra y sin
embargo en esta ocasión vamos a ver
matrices de una manera muy especial que
nos va a ayudar a hacer muchas
operaciones en un futuro lo que quiero
hacer en este vídeo es cómo operar
matrices con vectores qué operaciones
puedo hacer si yo tengo una matriz y un
vector y bueno para esto lo que voy a
hacer es definir la primera operación y
la primera operación que se me ocurre es
la multiplicación entre una matriz y un
vector entonces cómo puedo definir la
multiplicación de la matriz a por el
vector x y fíjate que am la estoy
poniendo en mayúsculas y en negritas y
el vector x voy a tomarme el vector
ahora bien para definir esta
multiplicación lo más importante es que
nos tomemos a un vector que tenga la
misma cantidad de componentes que las
columnas que tienen la matriz como en
este caso mi matriz general tiene n
columnas entonces mi vector tiene que
tener n componentes me voy a tomar un
vector que tenga en la componentes
supongamos que van a ser los componentes
x1 x2 así hasta x n pero eso es muy
importante fíjate en la cantidad de
columnas que tiene la matriz a que en
este caso son n y por lo tanto para
definir esta multiplicación mi vector
forzosamente debe de tener n componentes
de cualquier otra manera no está
definido esta multiplicación y bueno es
que esto es una definición nada en la
naturaleza nos dijo que de esto tenía
que ser de esta manera sólo que algún
ser humano o más bien algún matemático
decidió que esta es una convención útil
para definir la multiplicación de una
matriz con un vector es por eso que
recuerda que una definición no se
demuestra y es justo por lo mismo por
esta forma de definir
esta multiplicación que nosotros nos
vamos a tomar un vector que tenga la
misma cantidad de componentes que la
cantidad de columnas que tiene esta
matriz am entonces déjame ponerlo aquí
que nos va a quedar de la definición de
multiplicar la matriz a con el vector x
y recuerda que la matriz a es una
mayúscula en negritas y el vector
también se denota en negritas y con una
flecha arriba y bueno la multiplicación
de la matriz a por el vector x esto a
quién va a ser igual bueno pues nos va a
dar de resultado también un vector de
vector pues bueno lo que hay que hacer
es fijarnos en la primera entrada de la
matriz y multiplicando por la primera
componente del vector x es decir nos va
a quedar a 1-1 que va a multiplicar a x
1 entonces dejamos escribirlo aquí a 1-1
que multiplica a su vez a la primer
componente del vector x es decir x 1 más
a 12 que va a multiplicar a la segunda
componente de este vector a la
componente x2 entonces a 12 por x 2
y así nos vamos a seguir hasta llegar a
la multiplicación de la entrada a 1 n
por la última componente de este vector
por la componente x n y bueno esto es lo
que nos sale en la primera entrada de
este vector que va a ser el resultado de
esta matriz por este vector y parece un
poco al producto punto aunque ahorita
quiero ver con más calma las propiedades
de esta multiplicación por ahorita hasta
aquí vamos a decir que es la primera
componente de este vector porque después
la siguiente componente va a ser lo
siguiente ya me tomé la primera fila
ahora me voy a fijar en la segunda fila
y así sucesivamente y ahora vamos a
fijarnos en la fila 2 esta primera fila
la multiplique por todo este vector y
medio esto de aquí a continuación
modifica en la siguiente fila y dejamos
para esto tomar otro color me voy a
tomar en la segunda fila y también la
voy a multiplicar por el mismo vector
por todas las componentes del mismo
vector me va a quedar
a 21 que a su vez multiplica a x 1 + a
22 que a su vez multiplica a x2 estamos
haciendo lo mismo solamente con la
segunda fila más a 22 que multiplica a
la componente x 2 y después a esto lo
voy a seguir sumando sumando sumando
sumando hasta llegar a la suma de la
entrada a 2 n déjame ponerlo con el
color correspondiente a la entrada a 2 n
que a su vez multiplica a la última
componente este vector x n y bueno así
va a pasar para cada una de las filas de
este vector así para la que sigue así
para la que sigue así para la que sigue
hasta llegar pues claro a la última fila
de esta matriz es decir vamos a seguir
fila tras fila tras fila tras fila hasta
llegar a esta de aquí la cual la vamos a
multiplicar por las componentes del
vector x y me va a quedar a m 1 x x 1 m
1 aquí era 1 perdón m 1 que multiplica a
la primer componente del vector x es
decir x 1 ya esto le voy a sumar
a m2 que va a multiplicar a la segunda
componente del vector x es decir x2 y
así nos vamos a seguir hasta a mn que la
voy a multiplicar por la última
componente del vector x que es x en y
aquí ya tengo cada una de las
componentes de este vector que me dio de
resultado ahora bien como es un vector
pues déjame llamar a esto el vector b y
este vector de qué propiedades tienen
quién es este vector bien bueno primero
cuántas componentes tiene este vector
ven y si te das cuenta multiplique cada
una de estas filas por este vector x
entonces si tenían m filas ni efecto
resultante de esta operación va a tener
en componentes te das cuenta dicho de
otra manera lo que hice fue tomarme el
producto punto de cada uno de estos
vector fila por este vector x y este es
un concepto nuevo cuando hablo de un
vector fila lo que estoy diciendo es que
voy a descomponer a esta matriz a en
cada una de sus filas para así poder
tomar el producto punto con el vector x
y entonces fue justo lo que hice me tomé
la primera fila después
la segunda fila después la tercera fila
y así hasta llegar a la nueva fila y
bueno entonces podría decir que este
efector d tiene como componentes b1 b2
b3 hasta de m m componentes tiene este
vector b y entonces ya me estoy dando
cuenta que al menos puedo saber cuántas
componentes tienen mi resultado de esta
multiplicación que esté definiendo y es
que fíjate lo siguiente esto es muy
importante mi matriz am era una matriz m
por n en el filas n columnas mientras
que el vector x por otra parte si te das
cuenta tiene n filas y solamente una
columna precisamente por eso es vector y
cuando yo hago una multiplicación de
matriz por vector se puede cancelar
estos dos entonces nos va a quedar que
mi resultado va a tener m por 1 esa va a
ser la dimensión de mi vector resultante
es como se cancelará esta n estã n y
solamente me queda m x 1 m filas por una
columna y bueno todo esto es a lo que
llamamos a hacer una buena definición
entonces esta es mi definición de cómo
me voy a tomar el producto entre una
matriz
y así que vamos a reforzarlo con un
ejemplo no voy a tomar una matriz y
vamos a suponer que me tomo no sé se me
ocurre la matriz menos 3 032 esto es la
primera fila y después 17 menos 19
cuando el color amarillo ya se ve mucho
mejor todo esto y bueno entonces a esta
matriz la voy a multiplicar por un
vector y cuantas componentes tienen que
tener este vector pues bueno haciendo un
poco de memoria con lo que acabamos de
ver me vas a decir que debe tener las
mismas componentes que la cantidad de
columnas que tiene esta matriz así que
vamos a fijarnos cuántas columnas tiene
esta matriz una dos tres cuatro y
entonces por lo tanto en el vector tiene
que tener cuatro componentes que cuatro
componentes pues bueno voy a decir que
voy a tener los componentes 2 menos 3 4
y menos 1 aquí ya tengo a este vector y
bueno que me resulta de multiplicar esta
matriz por este vector pues bueno lo que
me va a resultar es otro vector aunque
sería muy bueno pensar en cuántas
componentes va a tener este efecto
y si te das cuenta esta matriz tiene dos
filas por lo tanto solamente vamos a
obtener un vector con dos componentes y
bueno hay que tomarnos el producto punto
del primer vector fila por este vector y
me queda menos 3 por 2 y después a esto
hay que agregarle 0 x menos 30 x menos 3
y después a esto termina tengo que
agregar 3 por 4 3 por 4 y después hay
que sumarle 2 x menos 12 x menos 1 y
bueno hay que hacer lo correspondiente
con el segundo vector fila que tenemos
en esta matriz es decir cuenta de aquí
abajo y me queda 1 x 2 + 7 x menos 37
por menos 3 más menos 1 por 4 + menos 1
por 4 y por último más 9 por menos 19
por menos 1 y bueno cuanto me va a dejar
del resultado esto pues vamos a
calcularlo me quedan tres por menos 2 me
da menos 60 por menos 3 chabán 0 por lo
que sea 0 entonces más 0 más 3 por 412
más 2 por menos 1 me da
y aquí abajo que me quedan dos por unas
27 x menos 3 es menos 21 después 1 x
menos 4 me da menos 4 y para finalizar
menos 21 es que parecía menos 4 - 21
menos 4 y menos 9 y bueno esto es igual
a menos 60 es menos 6 más 12 6 -2 es 44
positivo
2 - 21 menos 49 pues esto es lo mismo
que menos 34 2 lo cual es menos 32 este
y este es menos 30 menos 34 menos 34 más
dos me da menos 32 perfecto y entonces
ya tengo el resultado de esta
multiplicación de esta matriz por este
vector que yo tenía aquí al lado ahora
bien lo que quiero que veas en este
momento es que también podemos escribir
esto de una manera alterna es decir
podemos pensar que este equipo es un
vector fila este de aquí y bueno de
hecho lo podemos escribir de la
siguiente manera vamos a suponer que yo
digo que este de aquí es el vector
lo voy a poner de la siguiente manera el
vector a1 va a ser igual al vector a
menos 3 como es un vector tiene
solamente una columna menos 3 0 3 y 2 y
entonces voy a decir que el vector a 2
va a ser el otro el que está abajo es
decir 17 menos 1 y 9 y bueno ya que
tengo estos dos vectores ahora date
cuenta que para que yo forme la matriz
que tengo aquí arriba esta matriz que
está multiplicando este vector entonces
lo que me tengo que tomar son las trans
puestas de estos vectores es decir
fíjate bien si yo me tomo a uno que es
un vector columna ya este vector a uno
sacó su transpuesta entonces tengo que
cambiar todas las filas a columnas y las
columnas en filas y por lo tanto me va a
quedar menos 3 032 lo cual es un vector
fila y si yo calculo a 2 transpuesta
pues me va a quedar lo mismo solamente
que he visto como una fila es decir unos
7 menos 1 y 9 y bueno ya tengo los dos
vectores trans puestos y entonces fíjate
bien yo puedo decir que esta matriz que
tengo aquí
la puedo ver de la siguiente manera esta
matriz que tengo aquí es exactamente lo
mismo que pensar en a1 transpuesto el
vector fila a1 transpuesto y abajo tengo
pues el vector a 2 transpuesto y espera
déjame ponerle aquí arriba
este es el vector a 2 transpuesto y
estos dos vectores filas me forman a
esta matriz que yo tengo aquí arriba y
si a estos dos vectores los multiplicó
por el vector x voy a suponer que este
de aquí se llama mi vector x así que
déjenme ponerle nombre entonces este es
mi vector xy a esta matriz la voy a
multiplicar por un vector x entonces que
me da de resultado ojo estamos
encontrando una forma alterna de ver
cómo puedo escribir esta multiplicación
de una matriz por un vector y bueno voy
a hablar de justo lo que te decía hace
rato hablar del producto punto y si te
das cuenta en efecto resultante medio
esto
el vector a 1 punto x a 1 punto x
producto punto y es que date cuenta
si yo déjame cambiar de color y poner
aquí x si yo calculo el producto punto
entre 1 y x entonces me va a dar menos 3
x menos 2 + 0 x menos tres más tres por
cuatro más dos x menos uno y esto es
útil porque cuando definir el producto
punto solo lo definimos con vectores
columnas como éste yo no he definido
formalmente un vector fila y menos un
vector fila producto punto un vector
columna entonces puedo escribir un
matriz como los vectores trans puestos
de estos vectores columna es decir los
vectores filas y entonces cuando cálculo
la multiplicación de la matriz con el
vector pienso que cada componente del
vector resultante va a ser el producto
punto del inverso de la trans puesta de
estos vectores fila con el vector x
y de igual manera la segunda componente
este vector resultante quién va a ser
pues va a ser el vector a 2 punto
producto punto con el factor x otra vez
es decir 1 por 2 más 7 x menos 3 más
menos 1 por 4 + 9 por menos 1 lo único
que hice fue calcular dos productos
puntos y aquí tengo una forma alterna de
ver cómo encontrar este vector
resultante así que esta es una forma
distinta de poder encontrar la
multiplicación de una matriz por un
vector sin embargo aquí no acaba la cosa
también hay otra forma de ver esta misma
multiplicación de una matriz por un
vector y lo voy a ver aquí abajo y de
hecho sería bueno poner otro ejemplo
para ver esta nueva forma de definir
esta de multiplicación de la matriz por
un vector y entonces no voy a tomar a la
matriz a y fíjate que no quedó nada
muy bien delineada y voy a decir que es
la matriz
te voy a poner 3 103 después abajo 24 70
y después menos 1 2 3 4 y bueno a esta
matriz la voy a multiplicar por el
siguiente vector x y este vector va a
ser el vector
5 5 no derecho del córdoba ver de una
forma general x 1 x 2 x 3 y x 4 porque
recuerda que tiene que tener cuatro
componentes para que esté definida esta
multiplicación y bueno a continuación lo
que quiero que veas es que a esta matriz
a la puede descomponer en estos
siguientes vectores en este vector que
le voy a llamar el vector 1 en este
vector columna que le voy a llamar el
vector de 2 en este otro vector columna
que le voy a llamar el vector b 3 y por
último este último va a ser mi vector
columna b 4 entonces yo ya puedo ver a
la matriz a a negrita como quien como la
matriz que tiene como elementos al
vector b 1
el vector b2 aquí es b1 b2 b3 b4 ya que
nos facto el 4 entonces así puedo ver
ahora a esta matriz am como estos
vectores y cuando yo me tomo la
multiplicación de la matriz a por el
vector x entonces que me va a quedar
bueno déjame escribirlo aquí abajo date
cuenta que aquí tengo mis vectores aquí
tengo a mi vector x mis vectores columna
y ya más o menos te estás imaginando qué
es lo que va a quedar porque a x quien
es bueno pues esto es lo mismo que
tomarme y déjame escribir al menos la
primera componente para que te des
cuenta que es lo que me quedaría 3 veces
x 1 + 1 por x 20 x x 3 + 3 x x 4 esto es
lo que habíamos definido en el principio
del vídeo y aquí abajo me quedaría lo
siguiente y aquí tengo 2 x 1 + 4 x 2 +
todos los demás ya que abajo tendría
menos una vez x 1 + 2 x 2 + todos los
demás y es que al final lo que quiero es
que te des cuenta del siguiente patrón
si te das cuenta
vector columna siempre esta x x1 el
primer rector columna b 1 siempre esta x
x1 fíjate aquí tengo 3 x 1 2 x 1 y menos
1 x 1 al final lo que hice fue tomar
meses de efectuar columna en x x 1 y
después a esto le agregamos el vector
columna 2 el vector b 2 x x2 y después a
esto le agregamos el vector columna 3
por x 3
y por último le agregamos el vector
columna 4 b 4 por x 4 y entonces es que
al encontrar este patrón no estoy dando
cuenta que hay otra forma distinta de
escribir la multiplicación de una matriz
por un vector esto es exactamente lo
mismo que tomarme b 1 que multiplica a x
1 así que déjenme tomar el color
amarillo x 1 que multiplica el vector b
1 más el escalar x2 la segunda
componente de x x2 que multiplica al
vector 2 y después con amarillo déjenme
ganarme el color amarillo por b 2
pues y ya ves el patrón después me tomé
el escalar x 3 y lo multiplique por el
vector b 3 y después para finalizar me
tomé el escalar x 4 y lo multiplican por
el vector columna de cuatro y es que
date cuenta que tanto x 1 x 2 x 3 y x 4
son componentes de x y por lo tanto son
escalares y pueden ser cualquier tipo de
escalar en este caso no los tomamos de
forma general pero nosotros podemos
variar x 1 x 2 x 3 y x 4 y como podemos
variar estos valores entonces podemos
decir que la multiplicación en una
matriz por un vector la podemos ver como
una combinación lineal esto de aquí es
una combinación lineal y déjame ponerlo
combinación lineal de quien de los
vectores columnas de a porque al final
puedo variar tanto x1 como x2 como x 3
como x 4 y por lo tanto esto es una
combinación lineal de los vectores
columna de a y bueno estoy seguro que
alguna vez has visto la multiplicación
de matrices en el pasado pero realmente
quiero absorber estas dos maneras nuevas
interpretar esta multiplicación de
matriz por vector porque van a ser
importante cuando nos demos el tiempo de
hablar de cosas como los espacios
columnas y cortes fácil y al final no
solamente existen estas dos formas
nuevas de ver las multiplicación la
matriz por un vector sin embargo por la
brevedad del vídeo no me dan tiempo de
ver todas las demás formas de escribir
esta multiplicación aunque bueno puedes
recordar estas dos formas que una fue
ver esto como una combinación lineal de
los vectores con una dea y la otra fue
hablar acerca del producto punto de los
vectores fila trans puestos que a su vez
forman a esta matriz ampo en el vector x
por lo que al final se trata de dos
interpretaciones completamente válidas y
espero que al menos este vídeo te dé un
conocimiento de cómo se trabaja la
multiplicación de una matriz por un
vector y bueno también todas las
diferentes formas en las que se puede
interpretar esta multiplicación